[Music]
our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us
as americans is far greater than what
divides us so here's the situation this
morning more than 39 million americans
live
in low-income areas with limited access
to grocery stores think about that
according to the usda which tracks this
kind of thing
so this morning we're introducing you to
one farmer who is trying to
change that situation she's using her
farm it's a non-profit farm
the fight against racial inequalities in
our food system
aero barnett now shows us how leah
pennyman is helping families eat
healthier
and also opening the door for the next
generation of farmers
all of these are going to the refugee
center tomorrow over the past two
decades
this farmer and activist has plowed
through history and traveled the globe
i spent six months in ghana and i
learned from the women farmers there
using the momentum of the black lives
matter movement leah penneman is
stepping up efforts to combat
racism and injustice in the food system
she says that while violence against
african americans deserves the attention
it's getting
black americans are actually more likely
to die
from diet related issues i'm talking
about the mortality rates based on
cancer
diabetes kidney failure obesity
and heart disease all of that can be
linked all over the world you get your
food
it can be linked to whether you have
access to fresh fruits and vegetables
that it does not say that food issues
are more important
i think fundamentally we fail at
creating a racially just society if we
don't address
the interconnectedness between the
issues of mass incarceration
food injustice housing discrimination
and so on
soulfire provides fresh produce to
albany's underserved areas at little to
no cost
and serves as a means to end what she
calls
food apartheid the usda refers to spots
all over the country
as food deserts you don't have access to
fresh groceries
you use a different term food apartheid
why is that
the problem with using desert is it
implies a natural phenomena
but there is nothing natural about whole
communities who don't have access to
supermarkets so the reason we call it
food apartheid is because apartheid is a
human-created system of segregation
and anything that humans create we can
also undo
pennamon is also helping to educate
young aspiring farmers
like justin butts who runs his own
business
raising pigs i feel like if you're
eating meat you should be able to
take part in the food system in some way
then there's mother of two to shia ellis
we're getting fruits and vegetables
things that they
wouldn't have had otherwise so access is
key especially
in troy where we don't really have any
grocery stores that people who are
walking
can get to thanks to the resources
provided by the soulfire farm
ellis is able to pay it forward building
a community garden in her backyard
what are you getting out of this there
was this beautiful moment where this
four-year-old child
little black girl said when i grow up i
want to be a farmer like you
and so it's moments like that it's
moments when you drop off that box of
vegetables to people and they say if it
wasn't for this
all i would have is boiled pasta for my
children all week that feeds me and
makes me feel like i'm living
you know worthwhile life
boiled pasta will not do that's such an
important story well done errol barnett
thank you very much